une agriculture durable c'est ce que
nicolas hulot ministre de la transition
écologique et le ministre de
l'agriculture stéphane travert sont
venus découvrir à l'inra de versailles
dans ce laboratoire
emmanuel jacquin joly directrice de
recherche met au point une stratégie de
biocontrôle sur les insectes et leur
odorat
nous étudions l'odorat des insectes et
le goût des insectes donc leur sens
chimique pour essayer de mieux
comprendre comment ça fonctionne pour
finalement mettre au point des méthodes
qui vont les leurs et et perturbés dans
leur communication chimique et donc à la
base de nouvelles méthodes de
biocontrôle donc on peut faire des
pièges par exemple des pièges avec ce
type d'odeur on peut aussi faire de la
confusion peut mettre un petit peu
d'odeurs partout comme ça ils savent
plus trop y sent une méthode qui
permettrait d'éviter l'utilisation de
pesticides évoqué par nicolas hulot il y
a quelques semaines
une annonce qui avait provoqué un couac
avec son homologue de l'agriculture
cette visite se voulait aussi une
manière de prouver que les deux
ministres travaillent qu'ensemble nous
poursuivons le même objectif c'est que
demain nos modèles agricoles
quel qu'il soit puisse trouver des
débouchés des débouchés commerciaux
bien évidemment que les agriculteurs et
c'est le leitmotiv sur lequel je
travaille puissent vivre dignement de
leur métier
ce dont nous avons besoin c'est de
compléter notre approche il ya une
fenêtre d'opportunité pour faire prendre
modèle alimentaire au modèle agricole un
virage non pas à 180° non pas en jetant
tout l'existant mais en tenant compte
des paramètres des paramètres
climatiques de la demande des
consommateurs
l'ambition de souveraineté alimentaire
de la france on sortira ensemble par le
haut ou pas mais il y en a pas un qui
sera gagnant parce qu'on partage la même
ambition
une unité qui devrait se concrétiser fin
juillet avec les états généraux de
l'alimentation
un événement pour proposer des solutions
autour de la répartition des produits
alimentaires et sur le lien entre
alimentation et environnement